four days after a man was stabbed and
killed on an RTC bus his family is
sharing more about who he was while also
pushing to learn more about what
happened good evening to you at 11 I'm
Brian Loftus I'm Denise Valdez police
say the crime took place Sunday night on
Paradise near Desert Inn that's where we
find Sasha Loftus tonight live after
speaking to his sister Sasha
Denise and Brian police say Dominic
Lucas lost his life here along Paradise
just a few days ago when he was stabbed
on an RTC bus now I spoke with his
sister tonight she shared more about who
he was as family continues to grieve
nobody speaks on it Danisha Lucas
describes everything she loved about her
brother Dominic he didn't cause harm to
people he didn't do bad things he was a
family man police say 30 year old
Dominic Lucas was killed while riding
this bus to work on Sunday night he
wasn't a bad person at all and he did
not deserve that 59 year old Aaron Cole
is facing a murder charge after officers
say he stabbed Lucas multiple times
record show Lucas asked to be let off
the bus before this happened and the
driver pushed a button to alert police
he wanted to be led off the bus because
the man had threatened to kill him why
was he not let off the bus Cole has a
criminal history he was arrested on
February 16 for allegedly threatening a
person with a knife on a different bus
and was released three days before the
murder officials in Texas say Cole also
served 23 years in prison on a charge of
aggravated assault with a deadly wet he
was released in 2017. that's what we
want to know why now as Danisha and her
family are left to grieve she says
they're also doing whatever they can to
fight for justice we definitely want
answers
[Music]
now arrest reports also state that coal
was let on the bus with an expired
ticket due to quote a backlog of added
stops from last weekend's Marathon we
did reach out to the RTC about this and
they referred us to Metro for a comment
now the Lucas family has also set up a
GoFundMe to help with funeral expenses
if you'd like to help we have a link to
that on our website reporting live
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 news now Sasha
thank you from the passenger code of
conduct posted to rtc's website RTC
prohibits passengers from riding or
attempting to ride without proper bus
fare as well as physically attacking
passengers staff or the general public
now claimer notes that some substances
may involve individuals with
disabilities or medical conditions and
in those instances the RTC investigates
each violation individually